-I would imagine,
based on not liking
the crowds leaving,
the "SNL" New Orleans
Mardi Gras Special
must have been
incredibly traumatic, as well,
because,
for those who don't know,
this is the second season
of "SNL."
Lorne decided to bring the cas
down to do a live show,
live two-hour special,
at Mardi Gras,
which I believe
eliminated the decision
to ever try to do anything
like that ever again,
based on how it went down.
-It was such a good idea.
It was -- the planning that wa
involved was so meticulous
I mean, every --
every minute was counted for
We had -- not.
I was --
-[ Laughs ]
Did you think it was
a bad idea
when you first heard it?
-No, I thought
it would be really fun,
'cause, you know,
we're with a group,
and we would be well taken
care of and protected.
But it wasn't that way.
And I was doing
the color commentary
for the parade with Buck Henry
So, Buck and I didn't have any
rehearsal to do during the wee
because there was
no parade during the week,
so we just played,
and we just sort of
wandered around the street
during Mardi Gras.
Henry Winkler was in town, and
at that time, the Fonz was huge.
-Sure.
-And people thought
that Jack Lemon was in town,
and they thought
that Buck was Jack Lemon,
so they'd come up and say,
"Mr. Lemon, Mr. Lemon,
have you seen the Fonz?"
And Buck would go,
"Charles Street.
Charles Street,
about 10 minutes ago."
So we just had a great time.
Meanwhile, Gilda and Laraine
and Dan and John
are out doing sketches
or rehearsing sketches
in the middle of Mardi Gras,
and there's
no police protection.
So people are storming Gilda
They're accosting her.
They're throwing Laraine around.
I mean, it was just --
It was horrible.
It was just horrible.
But then, the day of the parad
happens and the day
of the show happens,
and Randy Newman opens the show.
He's in a --
the convention center,
and there's an audience there.
And I don't know who else
is doing the show.
And then,
they cut to the parade,
and there's Buck and me,
and we're sta-- we're sittin
on a platform
above the parade route,
and there are 15,000 peopl
who are really plastered,
shouting our names
and throwing bottles
and doubloons in our faces
And we're sitting there going,
"Well, the parade
should be here any minute.
We think it's gonna be great
and we heard that they were --
oh! -- lots of people --
ow! -- lots of people here
Lots of people here.
Buck, what do you think?
Lots of people."
-[ Laughs ]
It sounds horrifying.
-It was so horrifying.
And we were dodging doubloon
and all this kind of stuff
And there was a writer,
a sound guy,
a cameraman, and a P.A.
That's what we had
up in this little platform
So, at the parade route,
there was an accident.
So, I think
it was a fatal accident,
so the parade never happened
but...
-Oh, no.
-...it did in our minds.
So we described the parade
that we saw
coming down the street,
dodging doubloons and bottles.
The show ended,
and people are climbing up
onto the platform to get at us
-Sure.
-And -- yeah.
And the P.A. is stomping
on their fingers,
trying to pry them off.
And somebody screams,
"We need police protection,"
and somebody screamed back
"There are no policemen
available!"
So, Buck and I are going -
[ Shuddering ]
'Cause there are people
all around.
We couldn't get down.
They send two detectives,
two retired detectives,
guys in their 60s,
wearing trench coats,
you know,
a little bit of a beer belly
They come, and they said,
"Okay, okay, come on, come on,
come on down, come on down
come on down."
So we're climbing off
the scaffolding, climbing down
They grab us
in a fireman's hold,
throw us over their shoulders.
We're marching through the crowd
of 20,000 people.
I'm wailing,
I'm crying so hard.
Just the release of tensio
because I was saved
by these guys.
Buck, I think,
was in the same boat.
And when they went
to drop us to, you know,
to let us down and say,
"Okay, that's it,"
we didn't want to let go.
"No, no, I'm sorry.
I'll die if I let go of you.
I will die."
But they pried my little hands
off of his trench coat
and sent me off on my way.
-I'm so happy you went through
that so I never have to.
-Ah, well,
it was my pleasure, Seth.
-Was -- I always regretted
that I never got a chance
to meet Buck Henry.
Was he one of your favorites
-Yeah.
He was my all-time favorite.
Buck and I worked together
oh, for a long time after
"Saturday Night Live."
We did an NPR show
for 11 or 12 years
with Robert Krulwich
and Tony Hendra.
Buck and me and Herb Sargent
was the producer.
Yeah, you know,
we just hung out.
-That's great.
-Yeah.
-I guess once
you go through something
like New Orleans together,
you're probably
just like forever...
-It's true.
-Forever fused.
-Yeah, no, no, no,
we bonded, we bonded.
-Well, thank you so much
for being here.
Congrats on the new show,
and it's always
such a delight to see you.
-Good to see you, too, Seth.